seit rund einem jahr gibt es in
großbritannien ein ministerium für
einsamkeit und auch in deutschland wurde
über die einführung eines solchen
politischen amtes nachgedacht damit
sollen leben gerettet werden denn
studien zufolge ist einsamkeit nicht nur
ähnlich gesundheitsschädigend wie kette
zu rauchen
manche fachleute bezeichnen sie sogar
als eine epidemie sind längst nicht nur
mehr alte und alleinstehenden menschen
von diesem problem betroffen
doch was passiert eigentlich im
menschlichen körper wenn wir einsam sind
welche wege führen aus der einsamkeit
heraus kriegszeiten fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen auf der einen
seite wünschen sich viele von uns ab und
an mal einsam zu sein einfach mal zur
ruhe kommen und die sinne schärfen
doch auf der anderen seite haben viele
menschen auch extrem unter einsamkeit zu
leiden laut wissenschaftlichen studien
ist jeder siebte mensch einsam und das
bleibt nicht ohne folgen einsamkeit
wurde bereits in vielen
wissenschaftlichen studien untersucht
und die ergebnisse sind erschreckend
menschen die sich chronisch einsam
fühlen haben demnach eine erhöhte chance
einen schlaganfall herzinfarkt oder eine
krebserkrankung zu bekommen anders auf
den punkt gebracht einsamkeit ist so
ungesund wie das rauchen von 15
zigaretten pro tag doch wie können
forschungsteams herausfinden ob menschen
wirklich einsam sind viel zu einfach
wäre es dies allein an der intensität
und menge der sozialkontakte auszumachen
denn nicht alle fühlen sich einsam nur
weil sie öfter mal alleine sind
auf der anderen seite können sich
menschen einsam und unverstanden fühlen
obwohl sie viele kontakte in den
sozialen medien zum beispiel haben und
auch im realen leben einige
bekanntschaften haben entscheidend ist
das subjektive empfinden wünscht man
sich mehr gemeinschaft mit anderen
menschen leidet man unter zu wenig
kontakt und gibt es vertraute menschen
mit denen man persönliche dinge
besprechen kann beim menschen die bei
dem ausfüllen eines solchen fragebogens
hohe werte erreichen sind körperliche
veränderungen messbar der us
sozialpsychologe john cacioppo konnte
beispielsweise nachweisen dass bei so
isolierten menschen ein erhöhter
widerstand der blutgefäße vorhanden ist
ein faktor der die anfälligkeit für
bluthochdruck erhöht auch das level des
stresshormons cortisol war bei einsamen
menschen deutlich erhöht das bestätigen
auch die ergebnisse eines weiteren
forschungsteams die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus den usa hatten
herausgefunden dass einsamkeit zu einer
art stress hormonschub führen kann
erwachsene die sich abends beim
schlafengehen einsam und traurig gefühlt
haben zeigten am nächsten tag einen
erhöhten pegel des stresshormons
cortisol wird mit krankheiten wie
fettleibigkeit oder depression in
zusammenhang gebracht fest steht
jedenfalls ein langandauernder holte
hoher kortison spiegel aus dem im körper
cortisol entsteht ist nicht gut für
unsere gesundheit unser immunsystem wird
heruntergefahren wir schlafen schlechter
und blutdruck und blutzucker steigen an
zusammengefasst kann man also davon
ausgehen dass chronische einsamkeit
einen einfluss auf unser sogenanntes
sympathisches nervensystem hat und
dieses aktiviert wird der menschliche
körper wird damit auf eine drohende
herausforderung vorbereitet ein
notfallprogramm also und die frage
flucht oder ein kampf steht im raum laut
karachi rpo ein äußerst sinnvoller
prozess denn ein sozial isolierte mensch
kann nicht auf den schutz der gruppe
hoffen der evolutionsbiologisch gesehen
als überlebenswichtig gilt denn in der
prähistorie schützte das zusammenleben
in kleinen gruppen vor wilden tieren und
hatte weitere viele vorteile doch damit
nicht genug der forscher hat zudem auch
herausgefunden dass bei menschen die in
hohem maße einsam sind auch die gene
beeinflusst werden konkret war die
aktivität derjenigen gene erhöht die
entzündungen fördern
in einem weiteren experiment zeigte der
einsamkeit forscher karachi rpo
probanden die unter einen hirnscanner
lagen fotos von lächelnden menschen
das ergebnis war verblüffend im gehirn
derjenigen versuchsteilnehmer die sich
selbst als einsamer bezeichnet hatten
zeigte sich dabei weniger aktivität ein
indiz dafür dass sie sich über einen
solchen freundlichen kontakt weniger
freuen der hirnscan zeigte noch ein
weiteres ergebnis und zwar war auch die
gangs zone zwischen scheitel und
schläfenlappen weniger aktiv diese
hirnregion wird mit der fähigkeit in
zusammenhang gebracht sich in andere
menschen hineinversetzen zu können heißt
das also dass das gehirn von einsamen
menschen so strukturiert ist dass sie
von der nähe anderer menschen weniger
profitieren und sich auch deswegen
zurückziehen
fest steht also einsamkeit kann uns
krank machen doch die gute nachricht wir
können diesen gefühlen von einsamkeit
entgegensteuern und unserem körper beim
kampf gegen die einsamkeit helfen das
geht ganz einfach mal wieder jemanden in
den arm nehmen dann setzt unser körper
nämlich das hormon oxytocin frei das
wird oft auch als bindungs hormon
bezeichnung aktiviert unser
belohnungssystem
wir fühlen uns gut und es stärkt
gleichzeitig auch unsere sozialen
bindungen und noch etwas positives im
gegensatz zum rauchen beispielsweise hat
einsamkeit keine langweiligen
nachwirkungen auf unseren körper ein
paar nette bekanntschaften oder freunde
haben einen total positiven einfluss auf
unsere gesundheit also los gehts
kontakte sind echt wichtig ich will
deswegen war immer wieder ein community
treffen dieses mal in berlin machen wer
lust dazu hat schreibt sie in der
kommentare oder schickt mir eine
persönliche nachricht hier auf whatsapp
dafür hier klicken und ich suche mir mal
jemand jetzt zum knuddeln bis dann
bleibt dran